[Music]
the truth has finally been revealed a
couple days ago it came out Mitt Romney
is in fact a wealthy man you know we
weren't sure we weren't quite sure if I
was really wealthy right now the truth a
team like a hillbilly there kind of an
uptight hillbilly yeah well anyway on
Friday Mitt Romney disclosed his
earnings he is worth between a hundred
and ninety and two hundred and fifty
million dollars yeah Romney says there's
a 60 million dollar discrepancy because
there's still one pair of jeans where he
hasn't checked the pockets go check that
and then get back to us oh I heard it
people are wondering who his running
mate is gonna be some conservatives are
urging Mitt Romney to choose a Latino
running mate yeah yeah Romney said he's
torn between his gardener and his other
gardener
first he's just not sure he's got to
think about it while he's got it he's
got to know the guy yeah this is kind of
a cute story President Obama you
probably heard about this he wrote a
note for a fifth grader who skipped
school so that he could hear him give a
speech mister he wrote him a note yeah
yeah at first the boys teacher was
suspicious because the note was signed
billy's president no chanting of my name
now that sure killed the chanting real
fast you don't even know my name now
Donald Trump said something kind of
interesting Donald Trump
there's my trump right there the
quickest impression that's all you have
to do is pull your hair forward squint
like you ate a lemon
I'm here to teach you so you don't need
a host Donald Trump said that he is not
racist because he hired Arsenio Hall as
his celebrity apprentice now cuz nothing
proves you're not racist like hiring a
black man to work for you for free this
is crazy guards at Guantanamo Bay
apparently tried to coerce inmates into
giving information by playing the
inmates songs from Sesame Street yet it
worked one prisoner broke down and
confessed rubber ducky he's the one you
know the rubber ducky song I do
apparently they were asking who makes
bath time fun mic producer doesn't want
me to sing any of it as well then we
have to pay sorry right so there's a lot
of tension right now between my producer
and I he's like don't do it you do it
Rocky
you're the one they're gonna send Muppet
lawyers for you
you owe us money see new research just
came out I am not making this up
why would I where would I get the time
new research shows that elderly people
emit a distinct odor god the study was
conducted by two guys stuck in an
elevator with Larry King
[Applause]
universal sign for Larry King DC Comics
who's any DC Comics fans here
[Music]
why do I turn against my crowd I love
these people any creative answer like
complex and they cheer and then I mock
them right right it's terrible
well anyway DC Comics has revealed that
the Green Lantern is gay Bracken is gay
of course it's not a huge surprise
considering he's the only superhero who
gets his powers from his emerald jewelry
that should be a giveaway right there
where do your powers come from emerald
jewelry my emerald jewelry well and my
throat bill McDonough having a rough
time of it during a concert in Dubai
Madonna was booed by the Muslim crowd
yeah yeah apparently Madonna's burka
didn't completely cover her vagina
you